boulay cab podcast man we have a special
guest in here C5
yeah welcome man
thank you ma'am you brought gifts we
brought some wine
uh we have the tune core
speaker shout out to Encore we have a
book here that you can do things I'm
gonna I don't know what I'm gonna do
with this but I'm gonna write things in
it
independent as [__] uh we have some
drugs shout out not the plug yeah some
drugs and uh yeah not the plug let's
shout them out shout out not the plug oh
in a book
what is this book The Law of success by
Yogananda spiritual teacher
do you know Yogananda
uh he passed away I don't know him but
um sometimes me and my lady we go to the
self-realization center it's in a Malibu
you've been there she was telling me is
it the one that's uh the shrine lake
Lake Shrine yeah so you like pretty like
uh you know in tune with the uh the
manifestation and the uh meditation and
all that good stuff Jesus Christ my
phone will stop bro Blitz blowing me up
anyway uh like we would you just
consider yourself to be like a pretty
spiritually sound person
yeah for sure I feel like we all
spiritual yeah but um I just you know
I'm saying uh
I just spread love bro and I'm saying
everything manifests through the love I
I give out yeah no you've been doing
that I feel like that's I've I saw the
Russell freestyle you did with and and
Russell somebody who I feel like is like
kind of changing like
the way a lot of artists should be
thinking about their career and how they
do things and the deals they sign and
stuff like that so what kind of inspired
you to kind of take that approach with
some of your content and like giving
people flowers as opposed to like you
know doing like a normal freestyle or
something my queen
my lady she um
she had like seen that I could like you
know really make music about anything
any topic and she was like we started it
with my boy Matthew he got cerebral
palsy and she was like you should do a
song for Matthew
and um we did the song for Matthew you
know they Inspire him because like he
learned how to walk and things so like
we did a song for him you know surprised
them with it and man he was so touched
by it and then from there it was if she
was like oh yeah you should do one for
Trader Joe's and I was like we did
Trader Joe's that [__] went viral and
then it's now it's just been in this
whole um it's like a whole Lane you know
we've opened up and you know she uh she
with me there and I'm saying through all
the collaborations
she actually got a whole series called
roses like giving um Legends Day roses
while they started here yeah yeah so um
I've um we've collaborated on that like
we did one for Onyx and I did them a
song and I'm saying it was it was
amazing are you old enough to know about
Onyx yeah I know bionics but like you
know about him but you were you like are
you like an onyx fan I wouldn't say I
was a huge like you know um Avid
supporter but like yeah random 90s rap
group yeah I know I know more about
their movies you know what I'm saying
but like I was like I Like Big Al you
know what I'm saying amazing yeah yeah
so I was like I I gravitated to the east
coast right music where because you're
you're from out here I'm from Oakland
Okay you're from Oakland okay shout out
to Oakland man yeah the bay is a wild
place man don't get your car bipped out
there man keep your [__] on you when you
go into the store and get gas
everybody I know who goes to Oakland
gets their car broken into or even San
Francisco
it's crazy man have you like how often
do you go home
I haven't been in a while man my mom's
moved okay so I haven't been in um in a
minute but uh I should be going like the
next month or so I'm saying yeah all my
family kind of like moved to like
Atlanta and stuff so Oakland is still
where the Vibes are in the base San
Francisco is
just uh when you go it's like damn what
happened bro hmm it's rough there right
now yeah and then too like to speak on
like to go back to what we was talking
about man I want to encourage like
everybody to like you know let your let
your queen lead I'm saying if she come
up with an idea bro like if if I feel
like letting her lead and just taking
that and and just seeing what happened
bro like
y'all together you know what I'm saying
is it it can unfold things that's behind
beyond your imagination bro so I gotta
shout out my queen Penny Lane you know
I'm saying because she has she been real
supportive in my best and worst moments
and just you know seeing things and me
that I I ain't see right you know what
I'm saying and you know I'm saying vice
versa how passionate do you have to be
about Trader Joe's to make a freestyle
about them oh I love Trader Joe's you
know what I'm saying what we've really
seen like we we was like all right
what's all the things that we like like
what do you like on a daily basis like I
like Trader Joe's I like you know I like
Trader Joe's I like hot yoga um I [__]
with the Russell him it's like the [__]
that I actually really enjoy I'm gonna
[__] show appreciation to through
through the content right and it's it
always like creates this ripple effect
you know what I'm saying and it's you
don't lose nothing from
giving love you know what I'm saying did
you do any uh other freestyles about any
other artists besides the Russell I did
La Russell I did Lil Wayne so he was the
reason I even picked up the pen and
started writing I did um
who else we do baby
oh we did onyx
um
oh Viola Davis oh Viola Viola reposted
it she did she reposted it yeah that's
huge Nia Long shout out to me along he
reposted it did you do the Nia Long rap
prior or post the scandal with her ex
um
post post she probably needed that pick
me up it was probably nice for her to
see yeah yeah you know I'll do something
in there too like you know what I'm
saying like nah Quinn you deserve to be
treated you know I'm saying in the
highest regard
um who's next
who's next
um I got some people and I live I got
some uh I got some special I got
somebody special next I don't really
wanna I'm saying spoiler not a person
are you thinking about doing any like
other places or items next
um I really want to do one for high yoga
you know what I'm saying so I can go
there free man and and it's just like to
let people know like bro like I went
before I came here and that [__] is like
really healing bro like hot yogas
bro it's changed my life I'd be in there
having so many downloads and just like
when I'm not clear I'll go there and
just sweat it out and
bro yeah shout out Bridges like amazing
instructor and and teacher bro like yeah
today I was like man I was like it never
get easier right so I was like hey
Bridget like why why this don't never
get easier no matter how much I I come
and she was like it doesn't get easier
because you try harder and I was just
like just thinking about that with life
like I'm saying like we we always
striving for more
easier yeah
shout out Bridgette I was uh I'm like
worried about the scents of a hot yoga
situation the sense what you mean it's
just a lot of grown humans in there
sweating
it's hot someone busts ass in there you
know what I'm saying it just it just
feels like it could
I'm a very smell type of guy so I feel
like if it doesn't smell like I think it
smells in a hot yoga studio no no okay
and then you don't gotta worry about the
germs because um or not like that
because like heat AKA can't survive in
the heat so that works out I was going
through all through covet you were doing
yoga through covet yeah never never got
a never got sick you still still covered
free the whole time yeah cover free I
never had Coke so you're an anomaly I'm
immunicovid I just put that in the
universe and it just you know sounds you
might have had it though and you might
have just been asymptomatic I might have
had it but I'll never know I'm not
claiming it yeah yeah this guy is
natural immunity walking all right look
well look uh you got uh music out right
now
kind of push everybody to where they can
find your content where they can check
your [__] out man
um yeah C5 at official C5 on you know
Instagram at official C5 underscore on
Twitter
official C5 on YouTube I got 10 albums
out tick tock tick tock at official C5
got 10 albums out uh the latest is never
going back to the streets
um a whole album dedicated to my Queen
made a bunch of love songs about her and
hey why not you know what I'm saying
they really in love here huh I'm in love
bro how long you build this queen of
yours come here baby
real quick
I'm in love man
um we was best friends first
say what's up to the people if any land
you gotta kneel down nobody can see you
no
[Laughter]
Lane yeah yeah
um
we was best friends first for about two
years and then um you know we start
creating together and it turned into a
creationship
and then from that man it was just by
creating what do you mean
creating a like like we start
collaborating on you know experiences I
didn't know if this was like a new term
for you know
create yeah yeah you know building
experiences
um doing these songs for these these
artists or you know people that have
disabilities that need some
encouragement the brands we work with
some of the biggest brands super dope
yeah baby you got anything you want to
I'm saying Plug In before we get you
know saying get started I'm just proud
of you I'm proud of you thank you for
having us here today and just yeah
seeing the journey going from doing a
song for someone with cerebral palsy to
then doing a brand and then to having
just people reaching out beyond our
wildest expectations has been incredible
I think doing the the black light series
and highlighting Russell and Biola and
all these people just gave more exposure
of all the right people and things have
just really exploded and I feel like
that's why we're here today so boom and
thank you for recognizing you thank you
Penny Lane of course thank you boo it's
a great name
You Know This Woman's special like every
time I get a chance you know I'm saying
they're like
yeah y'all been like together together
um about um
about a year
I'm about a year you know what I'm
saying shout out to y'all yeah well
listen bro let's get to these wraps raps
yeah
turn me up a little hit in the
headphones shout out cleases
we're gonna do something a little
different today yes sir yeah
never going back to the streets go and
get my new album shout out bullet Kevin
bottom the man in L.A but grew up in
Arizona for 15 years straight been
giving back to the culture a radio
personality and a club owner when you
and Scottsdale make sure you pull up on
them 11 11 not as Divine timing before I
came on the show I visualized it cause I
didn't watch your interviews for years
now I'm finally here I could dance shed
a tear when we first met knew the energy
was pure you see also in the room I feel
em in the air Ready Set Studios come and
book a session Ready Set the label on a
song by Kevin hottest radio host from
Phoenix to Tampa real 92 3 7 to 11. he
did interviews with Wiz Rich the kid and
Freddie Gibbs and the one with Kevin
Gates that one had a lot of gems 2022
first time Arsenio DMS
hey I was trying to get it in 2022 in a
session here with Samba we chopped it up
I got your number but I was around
November you was on a plane when I sent
you through my music you was probably
busy and then get around to it 2023 [__]
you DM me Tommy come and spit say you
liking what you see now I'm in this
[__] remember it was all a dream shout
out Kevin thank you to GLD boom [__]
there it is
new album I had to pay my respects much
love man I appreciate you've been
putting in work I've been trying maybe
four hours even in the flesh okay
bootleg calf
I had to let them know
where the Charlemagne you deserve to
have a syndicated show much love brother
thank you man I appreciate you bro C5
man go run it up oh you got 10 albums
out the new album is uh never go back to
the streets never going back to the
streets is the new album dedicated to
your lady she's on the cover with you
right she on the cover with me I'm
saying real high vibrational and um
y'all better make this [__] work for
life because this is a lot we're putting
out here yeah we in this [__] for life
baby there it is yeah and thank you bro
thank you for your service thank you for
you know saying allowing me to come up
here and appreciate you man real quick
before we go what what made you be like
so I saw I think I saw your I think I
saw the little Wayne thing but I've been
following you since I think we met which
was last year right
but then I saw the little Russell thing
and I was like oh this [__] is
this [__] is like I respect the approach
um and I was like you know what it's
hard to
kind of differentiate yourself from
there's everybody's a content creator
especially every artist right so to me
when I saw the Russell [__] I was like
yo this is dope also because it's
somebody who I felt like
deserved that freestyle and I I like the
approach that you took because I was
like yo this is like a great way for
artists to
cut through and like get recognized
because everybody's doing a normal
freestyle everyone's doing some normal
rap [__] so it's like you know you're
obviously a talented artist you're
obviously super dope so it was dope just
kind of just see you uh
um
find a unique way to
Stand Out amongst the rest of the fools
you know what I'm saying yeah so I I I
[__] with it I was like oh this [__]
is hard and I obviously because I made
sure you have to send a video shoot
right was it the video shoot uh he was
in a he was in a session playing some uh
some music yeah yeah but yeah no I saw
that [__] and I was like okay yeah I
know we had talked and
I was like this is a dope approach to
just kind of it's new man it's something
different I feel like I'm when I see
something different it gets my attention
you know what I mean and it's something
different so I appreciated it you know
what I mean yeah I realized you know you
got to come sometimes sacrifice showing
these for the greater good of all bro
and honestly that's that [__] that like
will make people like really tap in with
what else you got going on
yeah I got 10 albums though man I've
been talking about me for years man so
like it feels good to like you know be
able to honor people that you know
inspired me you got to do a basketball
player I'm a basketball guy
or no are you are you a sports fan or no
okay then don't do it don't do it but
like Kobe I'm saying yeah yeah you got
me the Kobe would be easy rest in peace
here rest in peace but yeah shout out to
did you end up connecting with the
Russell obviously you reposted yeah I I
knew Larissa yeah I'm saying um I went
on a good company so I did a freestyle
because you've already been yeah
obviously chopped it up you got to go to
his house in Vallejo it's crazy yeah I
gotta go I ain't been the next time he
does this show like we win it was crazy
the next time he does a show you gotta
go yeah I'm gonna sing you that song too
like I laid it down for you oh word okay
good yeah yeah we're gonna fit it
together for you man I appreciate it man
thank you for pulling up C5 go follow
him go stream all his music 10 albums
worth God damn it and go uh you know
share his [__] hey I know you just
watched a new freestyle guess what we're
dropping them every week sometimes more
than once a week Jesus we've been
dropping a lot lately uh shout out to
LRG don't forget go to L Dash r-g.com
use the promo code bootleg say save 30
percent off at checkout you get this
look at this jacket look at that lining
it's LRG baby 30 off this bad boy go to
l-r-g.com promo code bootleg and save 30
off at checkout and check out another
freestyle next week